[Music]
a mountain separating two lakes a room
papered floor to ceiling with Bridal
satins
the lid of an immense snuff box these
seemingly unrelated images take us on a
tour of a sperm whale's head in Herman
Melville's moby-dick on the surface the
book is the story of captain Ahab's hunt
for revenge against Moby Dick the white
whale who bit off his leg but though the
book features parrots typhoons
high-speed chases and giant squid you
shouldn't expect a conventional
seafaring adventure instead it's a
multi-layered exploration of not only
the intimate details of life aboard a
whaling ship but also subjects from
across human and natural history by
turns playful and tragic humorous and
urgent the narrator guiding us through
these explorations is a common sailor
called Ishmael Ishmael starts out
telling his own story as he prepares to
escape the damp and drizzly November in
his soul by going to sea but after he
befriends a Pacific Islander Creek wing
and joins a Habs crew aboard the people
Ishmael becomes more of an omniscient
guide for the reader than a traditional
character while a hab obsesses over
revenge and first mates Starbuck tries
to reason with him Ishmael takes us on
his own quest for meaning throughout the
whole universe not excluding its suburbs
in his telling life's biggest questions
loom large even in the smallest details
like his narrator Melville was Restless
and curious spirit who gained her
unorthodox education working as a sailor
on a series of grueling voyages around
the world in his youth he published Moby
Dick in 1851 when the United States
whaling industry was at its height
Nantucket where the Pequod sets
was the epicenter of this lucrative and
bloody global industry which decimated
the world's whale populations unusually
for his time Melville doesn't shy away
from the ugly side of this industry even
taking the whales perspective at one
point when he speculates on how
terrifying the huge shadows of the ships
must be to the creature swimming below
the author's first-hand familiarity with
whaling is evident over and over again
in Ishmael's vivid descriptions in one
chapter the skin of a whale's penis
becomes protective clothing for a
crewman chapters with titles as
unpromising as cistern and buckets
become some of the novel's most
rewarding as Ishmael compares bailing
out a sperm whale's head to midwifery
which leads to reflections on Plato
tangling whale lines provoked witty
reflections and the ever-present perils
in tangling all mortals he draws on
diverse branches of knowledge like
zoology astronomy law economics
mythology and teachings from a range of
religious and cultural traditions the
book experiments with writing style as
much as subject matter in one monologue
a had challenges Moby Dick in
Shakespearean style towards thee I roll
thou all-destroying that hung conquering
whale to the last I grapple with thee
from hell's heart I stab at thee
for hates sake I Spit my last breath at
me one chapter is written as a play
script where members of the Pequod's
multi-ethnic crew chimed in individually
and in chorus African and Spanish
sailors trade insults while a Tahitian
seaman longs for home Chinese and
Portuguese crew members call for a dance
and one young boy prophesized disaster
in another chapter
Ishmael sings the process of decanting
whale oil in epic style as the ship
pitches and rolls in the midnight sea
and the casks Rumble like landslides a
book so wide-ranging has something for
everyone
readers have found religious and
political allegory existential inquiry
social satire economic analysis and
representations of American imperialism
industrial relations and racial conflict
as Ishmael chases meaning and a hub
chases the white whale the book explores
the opposing forces of optimism and
uncertainty curiosity and fear that
characterize human existence no matter
what it is we're chasing
through movi dicts many pages Melville
invites his readers to leap into the
unknown to join him on the hunt for the
ungraspable phantom of life for more
harrowing tales of monstrous obsessions
check out our video on Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein or start conjuring up some
metaphors of your own with the help of
this video
[Music]